regardez ce qui arrive à gâteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m
les services de sécurité
j'avais demandé à toutes les personnes
du public et toutes les chroniqueurs de
ne pas bouger parce que je vous le dis
le sol la somme c'est un enfer et même
les cas bon
je vais demander joseph de ne pas bouger
personne
ne bougeait pas salut je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
même penser même si nantes et malik
pensez que vous allez en mettre un peu
partout mais paypal et paraît mal à cela
le public le public mais vraiment vous
avez du bol ce soir ils en ont pris
plein la tronche et vous vous êtes ni
d'ailleurs à laisser la bride j'ai
laissé mon poignet droit la chose qu'on
voit la wii vous avez donné pour l'insee
pour le public et bien c'est ça qui est
beau fixe
[Applaudissements]